here is the stuff of which
fairy tales are made let me tell y'all
you are not ready season four of the
crown just dropped this delicious new
trailer anne
oh and this is the moment fans
of the series have been waiting a long
time to see i'm like getting hot just
thinking i'm
getting hot watching you guys indeed
it's the story of charles
and diana the prince and princess
on their wedding day did it kind of
freak you out just
how similar you two look like them as a
couple
i was seeing in front of a mirror and
there was a picture of her behind me for
reference
and i remember tilting my head in the
same way during the wig fitting and
everyone going
oh it's because we have such a clear
memory of diana
and so when emma steps out with the wig
and the amazing costumes
it was spooky it was like really
haunting i thought
to prepare for her role 24 year old emma
corrin watched hours of diana videos and
even met with dye's former private
secretary
but it was the 80s fashions that really
helped her to channel the people's
princess
i just love going in every day and it'd
be like a new incredible costume hanging
in my trailer it was mad what was your
favorite
i didn't actually think it was the
wedding dress i mean because it's so
spectacular that it kind of can't
compete
diana's wedding dress had a 25 foot silk
train
and a 153 long veil made of tulle
david emanuel who co-created dye's gown
consulted with the show's wardrobe
department
the result is an almost identical
replica that took
10 people to help emma put it on
season four of the crown drops on
netflix november 15th
and we gotta wonder if the duke and
duchess of sussex will be binging
megan and harry have a netflix deal what
would you want for him to take away from
kind of seeing this play out enjoy it as
a piece of drama that's what it is